now I know you have two of these already
at home you seem genuinely shocked when
they announced your name I was
out of never I'm the one who never
expects this
yeah I fell on the stairs I mean that's
did you okay that's good because some
people didn't know I did that was a
little one two step no I mean I really I
had I was stuck I was trapped in my
dress and I had very nice men helping me
so that was a plus
um but yeah no I'm I'm always shocked
I've never expecting that this would
ever happen so it's a huge surprise and
a wonderful surprise so where's this one
going and how are you celebrating it's
going with the other ones and
um I'm celebrating and what's wonderful
is they're all in different categories
it's beautiful and um
yeah I just owe it to my entire cast who
was in the show with me and to Mike
Shannon my my comrade in arms in this
series
thank you and also I have to acknowledge
the woman that I was in the category
with Emily and Amanda and Julia and
Niecy I mean I've seen all of their
performances and it's this category was
stacked
so it's it means a lot to to be with
them that explains the shock in your
face a lot yeah I was
deserve congratulations thank you
[Music]
foreign